so while we're confident that inflation
will come down this year developments
over the coming quarters will be crucial
in determining how quickly overall
inflationary pressures of Bates
judging sustainability requires us to
look further ahead and that's where the
uncertainties increase
your policy committee's best Collective
judgment the most likely outcome is that
an increasing degree of economic Slack
alongside reduced external pressures
leads Consumer Price inflation to fall
below the two percent Target from around
spring 2024 next year
besides the market implied path for bank
rate this is conditional on a wholesale
Energy prices following their respective
Futures curves over the whole forecast
period
so in other words the forecast suggests
that inflation will come down and that
it will fall quite sharply
but events May not unfold in this way
with inflation currently above 10 we are
in an Uncharted Territory
Energy prices may not fall by as much as
currently expected in financial markets
and even if they do this period of very
high inflation could play into price and
wage setting in the UK economy to a
greater extent than we assume in our
Central projection
tightness of the labor market reinforces
this risk
for this reason we think the risks
around our Central projection for
inflation shown in this chart are skewed
significantly to the upside
and more so than at any time in the
history of the military policy committee
our decision to increase bank rate today
despite a weak Outlook in our Central
projection reflects these uncertainties
uncertainties over the extent to which
external and domestic inflationary
pressures develop over the coming
quarters
and wider uncertainties over the
trajectory of the economy
and inflationary Dynamics further ahead